-House Republicans defied
Donald Trump on a secret ballot
to choose their nominee for
the next Speaker of the House.
But the chamber is still
completely paralyzed
as Republicans scramble
to get the votes together
in a process that has been both
very chaotic and very weird.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As we have said many times
on this show,
Donald Trump weirdified
the Republican Party.
They were always weird,
but for the most part,
they had enough shame
to keep their weirdness hidden.
But then Trump came along
and unleashed
an army of mutant freaks like
Mike Lindell or Rudy Giuliani,
seen here attempting
to hypnotize you into forgetting
that he is wearing
a pair of child's khakis
as his golf shorts.
[As Giuliani]
You're getting very sleepy.
But wait! That's me!
I'm getting very sleepy.
Must have been
my breakfast whiskey.
It doesn't make the Cheerios
soggy like milk does.
[Normal voice]
There was no reason
to show you that video today.
None at all.
But it's the best.
So why not?
There was a point.
Oh, yeah!
Donald Trump...is weird.
For example, he's a big fan
of Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan,
who Trump recently endorsed
for Speaker of the House.
In the past, Trump has praised
Jordan for the weirdest reasons.
For example, Jordan rarely
wears a suit jacket,
and Trump noticed that
and took away the weirdest
possible interpretation.
-When I first got to know Jim,
I said, "Huh!
He never wears a jacket.
What the hell's going on?
He's obviously very proud
of his body."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I guess we know
how Trump feels about his body.
If his jackets
were any bigger,
they would technically
be cocoons.
And again, I know
everybody stopped
caring about hypocrisy
years ago,
but just imagine
how conservatives would react
if Joe Biden was out
on the stump
talking about
the body positivity
of the men
in the Democratic Party.
"I'll tell you,
our caucus right now
is just one Gosling
after the other."
Now, as I mentioned,
Trump endorsed Jim Jordan
to be the next
Speaker of the House.
Jordan ran against Louisiana
Congressman Steve Scalise
for the GOP nomination,
and the conference voted
on Wednesday in a secret ballot.
In fact, the ballot
was so secret,
they made everyone
put their phones
in manila envelopes
before entering the room.
Unfortunately, Republicans
accidentally put stamps
on all those envelopes and their
phones got mailed to the FBI.
"Boss, you're not
gonna believe this,
but we just cracked the case."
"Which one?"
"All of them!"
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump endorsed Jim Jordan,
and Trump proudly touts
his control
over the Republican Party,
claiming the people
he endorses always win.
So Jordan must have
cruised to victory, right?
Back me up, clip!
-We have breaking news.
House Republicans have nominated
Steve Scalise moments ago
as their new speaker.
-Trump endorsed Jordan,
you know,
more than maybe
about a week ago.
So a big loss
for Trump here, as well.
-Ooh, Trump's not gonna
be happy about that.
[As Trump] Steve Scalise
is a loser and a nobody.
And on top of that,
he wears a jacket.
Unlike Jim Jordan,
who has a terrific body.
You know, I always thought
members of Congress should
dress like Chippendale dancers.
Chippendales.
We love Chippendales, don't we?
You know, for a long time,
I thought it was Chip and Dale,
and I was very surprised
that bachelorettes wanted
to go to a place where chipmunks
would give them lap dances,
because they may look cute,
but they're filthy animals.
They're filthy.
You don't want them
near your lap.
They're just rats
with nicer coats.
[Normal voice] So, Steve Scalise
is now technically
the GOP's nominee for speaker,
but that doesn't mean
he has enough votes
to actually become speaker.
Once the full House
goes to the floor to vote,
he has to keep making promises
to people to get their votes,
just like now former speaker
Kevin McCarthy did.
The situation
has been so chaotic,
reporters are just grabbing
members of Congress
in the halls at random,
live on camera, to ask them
who they're voting for.
-As we watch one of
the defectors walk by now,
one of the people who ousted
Kevin McCarthy, Tim Burchett.
Mr. Burchett, you gonna vote
for Mr. Scalise on the floor?
-Absolutely.
-Thank you, Congressman.
He's on board -- Steve Scalise.
There's some news just now.
He is gonna be on the Scalise
board, the Scalise train.
But there are others at this
moment who have yet to commit.
-That's how much of a mess
Republicans have made
of this situation.
They've turned
professional reporters into guys
handing out fliers for
comedy shows in Times Square.
"Hey, you want to come see
some comedy? It's free."
By the way,
what kind of crappy comic
would need to hand out fliers
for a show in Times Square?
Oh, son of a bitch!
So, the GOP infighting
has been a mess.
It's also been, as we mentioned
before, incredibly weird.
For example, Wyoming
Congressman Harriet Hageman
showed up to GOP forum
on Tuesday holding a lasso.
Is she gonna vote for a speaker
or try to catch one?
That's how [bleep] the job
of Republican speaker is --
they've got to hog-tie you down
just to make you take it.
Is this a meeting to elect
a new Speaker of the House
or a county fair?
After they choose a speaker,
are they also gonna judge
who has the biggest pumpkin?
Which brings us
to a segment called
"We Could Have Made
a Trump Joke Here."
[ Laughter ]
Are they also gonna judge
who has the biggest pumpkin?
And then we're just
gonna let it go.
We're better than that.
We've moved on
from that kind of joke.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if we were gonna
make a joke
about the biggest pumpkin
in the GOP, you know,
we'd show you this picture.
[ Laughter ]
Now, that's a photo
we're never gonna retire,
especially now that
it's Halloween season.
Imagine that thing
sitting on the porch
waiting for trick-or-treaters.
Wouldn't you want to see
what it would look like
if Rudy was
one of those paintings
whose eyes followed you
around the room?
Well, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
But, of course, a lasso was not
the weirdest fashion choice
at the GOP conference this week.
As we mentioned yesterday,
South Carolina
Congresswoman Nancy Mace
showed up wearing a shirt
with the letter "A,"
which she said
was a scarlet letter
because she voted
to oust former speaker
Kevin McCarthy last week
and got criticized for it.
-I'm wearing the scarlet letter
after the week
that I just had last week,
being a woman up here
and being demonized for my vote
and for my voice.
-Okay, but that doesn't look
like the scarlet letter.
That looked like you stole
the last letter
of the Chick-fil-A logo.
[ Laughter ]
Mace is one of the holdouts
threatening to tank
Scalise's speakership bid.
She told CNN's Jake Tapper
yesterday
that she would vote for Jordan
when it got to the floor.
And she even claimed
there were some Democrats --
not Republicans, Democrats --
who said they could trust
Jordan, one of the most
pro-MAGA members of Congress,
who helped instigate
the January 6th coup.
And her claim left Tapper
in stunned disbelief.
-Well, I think Jim Jordan
is not out of the mix.
I've talked to a lot of people
who still support him.
I've actually
talked to Democrats
who trust him at his word.
I don't think that's out
of the realm of possibility --
-Jim Jordan?
-Yes, I've talked to Democrats
over the last week
on who do they trust,
even though they wouldn't agree
with him on many issues.
He is someone --
-The Jim Jordan from Ohio?
-Oh, yes, the Jim Jordan
from Ohio. I talk to people --
-Democrats in Congress?
-Yes, they can work with him,
and those that I have --
-Name one Democrat from Congress
that trusts Jim Jordan.
-I'm not gonna name people
off the record.
They trust him more than
they trust the former speaker,
in my private conversations
with Democrats.
-The worse Republicans get,
the sassier Tapper gets.
"The Jim Jordan from Ohio?
With the rockin' bod?"
[ Laughter ]
We said it yesterday,
and we'll say it again today.
Republican Party,
you just got tapped.
[ Air horn blasting ]
[ Guitar solo ]
[ Man screams ]
[ Laughter ]
But regardless of who wins
the speaker vote,
they're both extremists,
they both voted to overturn
the 2020 election
on January 6th,
and neither will acknowledge
that Joe Biden was
the legitimate winner,
which led Colorado
Congressman Ken Buck to say
he couldn't vote
for either of them.
-I asked last night,
"Will you unequivocally
and publicly state
that the election,
the 2020 presidential election,
was not stolen?"
He didn't answer
that question very clearly,
and Jim Jordan didn't answer
that question very clearly.
-Something as simple as saying
the 2020 election wasn't stolen,
why don't you think either
one of those gentlemen
can commit to that?
-I think there is a large group
of Trump followers
in this country
that would disagree with that,
and would -- there would be
a political penalty
for saying such a thing.
-Yeah, Republicans
are so desperate
to please the Trump base,
they're doing
increasingly dumb [bleep]
bringing, like, a lasso
to a meeting
or dressing like an off-brand
Captain America
your grandma would get
at a dollar store.
"The man at the store said
this one is just as good!
You just can't eat the paint
or leave it out in the sun.
She was right next to
discount Wonder Woman."
[ Laughter ]
But that explains
everything right there.
Republicans are terrified
of the Trump base
and pro-Trump media, even though
it does not represent
and has never represented
a majority of Americans.
It hasn't even come close.
But it's a big enough part
of the GOP base
to make Republican
politicians afraid,
which is why
they could only vote
against Trump's pick for speaker
when it was a secret ballot,
because they all know
the truth --
Trump is a dangerous
aspiring dictator
who wants to dismantle
American democracy,
and who looks like a pumpkin!
Alright, fine, we said it!
Sue me!
We had one Trump pumpkin.
We've been waiting hard.
You know what?
We've worked hard.
We've worked two weeks
in a row.
Yeah, I know we had
five months off before that,
but that's two weeks
in a row.
Name one other American
who's done that.
[ Laughter ]
When they write the book
on me one day,
I just hope they say
that Seth Meyers
wasn't proud of that joke,
but he is...
-Very proud of his body.
[ Laughter ]
-No jacket, baby! No jacket!
[ Laughing ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]